how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all a howl I
guess in virtual reality pornography is
already with us along with predictions
that secretary books become place by
2025 many of us or some of us believe
this threatens to corrupt love and
undermine relationships it's some think
it will be the ultimate liberation so
joining us to discuss our Kate Devlin
Kate is a computer scientist and senior
lecturer at Goldsmiths University
specializing in AI and human-computer
interaction Alan Winfield is a professor
of Robotics at university of the west of
england Bristol and an expert on AI and
cognitive robotics and Brickman yachty
is best known by her pen name Belle de
Jour she's also an award-winning blogger
a research scientist and the author of
Sex Lies and statistics the opening
question is a very simple one are sex
robots a threat to human relationships
or sex robots a threat no no they're not
going to be a threat so I spent I spent
the past three years researching sex
robots I spent the past year writing a
book on them and trust me the headlines
you see about them are so incredibly
misleading first of all they've only
just emerged commercially there is one
built by abyss creations who made real
dolls if you've ever seen the film Lars
and the real girl it's one of those with
an animatronic head and an AI
personality and that's it
that's what we have we have basically
emotionless sex dolls with a bit of
Robotics thrown in the sex robots that
we have today all very pornified hyper
sexualized female forms have come out of
the sex doll market and sex dolls are
bought high-end sex dolls are bought by
people for a number of different reasons
there's tends to be too many areas
people who fetishize them people who buy
them for companionship and they treat
them very respectfully these people are
not all what you think of the isolated
lonely man and they're in their bedrooms
these are people in relationships these
are people with psychological issues or
people who just feel lonely people who
buy them just to photograph them or
collect them
so I think the sex robot market in this
form is incredibly incredibly niche
there's being taught recently will sex
robots stop in cells from from hurting
women in cell and voltar celebrates the
people who the example being the the
person in Toronto who drove a van into
people in the street was part of this
movement very misogynistic movement I
don't think they will because I think
these are misogynist who will who will
hurt women no matter what they have at
their disposal lots of threats around
sex robots and this idea of will they
destroy relationships I don't think so
but I think what we what we can do
there's great benefits to new forms of
sex technology so if you think of the
sex toy over years and thousands of
years it's morphed from replica human
genitals to something very abstract and
very design II the sort of thing you
could put on your mantelpiece and say
it's an ornament I have many of them on
my mantelpiece they work and I think we
can see that if we thought about how we
rather than building sex robots robot
specifically for the purpose of sex
which quite frankly we are terrible at
making human robots were really rubbish
at it and they always look awful if we
move away from the human form into more
embodied type of sex toys full-bodied
immersive experiences blankets that can
hug you and Stroke you and dr2 stream
from your wearable into some kind of
vibrating device I think we can do much
better so I think we can use the
technology to enhance human to human
relationships rather than replace it and
I think this terrified dystopian fear
that will be replaced by robots it's
just another one of a very long
narratives where robots will come and
replace us and it's about loss of agency
we're very worried about robots taking
over whether it's for jobs or for to be
our lovers so I think this is a
something we see with the introduction
of all new technology and this is just
another example of that fear
Alun windshield our sex robots of
threats of human relationships
well I maybe but I'm really going to
focus not on human relationships like I
can't because I'm not a sociologist I'm
an engineer and an ethicist so I'm going
to think more broadly about if you like
the threats to society and humanity in
general and I should say that you know
as a robot ethicist my job is to be a
kind of professional worrier so what I'm
going to do is to share with you some
worries and the first one is that I
think we should be worried about the
safety of sex machines now I speak as an
old-fashioned safety engineer I spent
many years working on safety critical
systems and you know there's a very good
reason that mostly most of the robots in
the world today are kept away from
people they're not safe but think sex
robots and you need to think machinery
hmm
not a good combination machinery
intimate contact and you know as someone
as Joe Heder said who works on standards
I think the likelihood that the British
Standards Institute publishes a standard
on the specification and safety
certification of sex robots is pretty
slim
okay now Kate introduced the idea of you
know what exactly is a sex robot and of
course you know the press the the hype
is around robots that look like people
and I have to say that I have a
long-standing principled objection to
any robots that look like people so I
don't you know whether it's a sex robot
or a robot policeman I don't think we
should be building robots that look like
people why not because it's a deception
robots are not people and any robot that
that resembles a person is effectively
it is deceiving you
sounds like a sex rip River proteins
isn't it let's read let it pass so
there's the machinery of which I speak
no it's fine and and I'd like to really
develop that to a kind of deeper ethical
concern
so consider the intelligence of a robot
now a robot is essentially a machine
with an embodied artificial intelligence
it's the AI that makes an intelligent
robot intelligent now right now the
smartest robots that we have are about
as intelligent as your washing machine
so you know we needn't be too concerned
perhaps maybe maybe we should but the
point is consider a slightly more
intelligent machine you know it's it's
perfectly conceivable within the next
year or two we'll have robots that have
animal-like intelligence now you know
think about an animal like intelligence
in the context of of sex robots so you
know sex between consenting adult humans
of course is sex between equals but it
seems to me and this is really a
provocation shahida for discussion it
seems to me that there's something
profoundly unequal and in fact
disturbing perhaps even abusive about
sex between a human and a robot that
looks like a person but has subhuman
intelligence
minyan TR sex relationship I would say I
would say no but I come into it
obviously from a very different angle I
think that we're all probably on this
panel agreed that the sort of technology
that people are afraid of something that
fully mimics a human woman Allah the the
cult classic cherry mm is not only a
long way off it's it's not in many many
generations lifetimes from ours that
what computing would have to be able to
do so we can we can kind of take that
idea and set it aside because we do have
robots the turn back flips and we have
robots that win at chess these are not
the same robots and also their
intelligence is not generalizable my
washing machine cannot also cook my rice
it can't take what it's learned about my
wash and apply that to another problem
which is great news but quite recently I
saw a take in the press that was
actually saying sex robots will be great
because they will replace sex workers
and then no woman has to be abused as a
sex worker again obviously I have
problems with this as a former sex
worker when we think about sorry my
cultural touchstones for things like
this our Star Trek The Next Generation
we had mr. data who could physically
make he looked humanoid he could
physically mate with a lot of different
species but he really couldn't give you
a pillow talk and if it's just the act
of getting somebody to reach orgasm that
constituted what sex work is and what
sex is I would not have been that
effective and escort because it would
just be people turning up they want the
chat they want the human interaction
when you look on things like they're
absolutely horrible but the review
boards for escorts the most cutting
thing that a client can say about an
escort is that she was robotic that
would kill your career overnight so it's
only ever going to be a minority of
people the love dull people who want a
fleshlight that talks to them get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in dog